[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness what a beautiful Studio
we're excited thank you they told me
they didn't have money for nice
Studios I love being in this building
with you you it's a great building I
have to say this you were the very first
person when we announced that we were
coming to New York he sent me a like
handwritten card like saying welcome to
dirty Rock I'll show you around the
commissary which by the way has really
good food it's an excellent commissary
that was the first thing I was going to
tell you you said it in the card and you
brought it for I was like I don't know
cuz like a cafeteria Can it can be it
could be I started here in 2001 and uh
the cafeteria in 2001 was a dump okay
okay I came at the right time they
rebuilt the commissary and I I take it
to the streets I brag about it
everywhere I go so it's so good great I
love being you do have to pay for the
food I've heard about you at previous
place is that you there's an assumption
because you're Kelly clar so you can
just take the food and walk right out
but I do out Ro so I'm just I love
[Music]
[Applause]
food thank you guys y have a great night
I'm going
home